c'est la dernière ligne droite pour les
600 danseurs amateurs du stage
international d'arc
ce soir le festival touche à sa fin avec
le spectacle final
l'aboutissement de quinze jours de haute
intensité les deux semaines on arrive à
créer quelque chose de fur et à mesure
des jours
il ya l'investissement des élèves la
rigueur la motivation qui font que ils
sont à l'écouté
ils sont appliqués en fonction de leur
niveau on va pas leur demander des
choses trop compliquées
le but c'est qu'ils s'amusent qu'ils
aient du plaisir sur scène
le thème de ce grand final à chacun son
roméo à chacun sa juliette
[Musique]
pour mourad bois yade ce fut une
première en tant que chorégraphe le
festival darc
parmi les amateurs qu'il dirige certains
n'avaient même jamais dansé avant le
début du stage j'ai un groupe assez
réduit c'est un gros avantage pour
concéder un spectacle puisque j'avais à
dire est qu avec une vingtaine de
personnes et y en a certains qui
travaillent 180 180 personnes malades
dans leur show donc j'ai eu la chance
que j'avais vraiment le temps du tout le
monde était vraiment engagés et
concentrés
au total ce sont 65 mille spectateurs
qui auront pris place dans les tribunes
sur l'ensemble du festival ce soir
jusqu'à 5000 personnes sont attendues
pour le final y'a pas cette ambiance
très compétitif traçantes au final c'est
ce que du fun on est tous là pour
s'amuser c'est pas c'est pas hyper
stressant oui il ya une petite pression
quand même parce qu'il ya pas mal de
monde mais mais on se réjouit tout cela
vraiment c'est pour bien terminer le
stage c'est parfait
modern jazz danse africaine ou
claquettes nombreux seront les styles
mise à l'honneur pendant trois heures ce
soir à châteauroux
rendez vous à 20h45 nous nous retrouvons
donc en compagnie d'éric bailey
directeur artistique du festival darc
une belle et bonsoir bonsoir alors
quatre à cinq mille personnes on l'a dit
sont attendus ce soir sur l'ensemble du
festival sont 65 mille spectateurs qui
se sont présentés pour venir assister
aux différentes représentations
est ce qu'on peut dire que cette 43e
édition du festival c'était un un succès
et une réussite
animant succès puisqu'au niveau du stage
international plus de 650 stagiaires qui
viennent à peu près de 20 pays
différents
et puis au niveau du festival 65000
personnes dako pays en zone rurale 6 à
7000 personnes non vraiment le soleil
était au rendez vous mais le succès de
la manifestation est indéniable ça a
dépassé vous attendent peut-être oui
complètement parce que parfois on est
inquiet avant la manifestation
là il ya une ambiance de travail est
l'aboutissement c'est ce soir avec le
spectacle final qui va réunir tous les
stagiaires
alors du côté de la musique on a eu des
grosses têtes d'affiché comme amirou
gauvin serre et du côté de la danse donc
près de 650 stagiaires ils sont de
l'international pour ceux se
représentait donc devant le public de
châteauroux est ce que ça peut servir de
tremplin
ce festival oui ça peut servir de
tremplin pourquoi parce qu'elle y à des
chorégraphes et professeurs qui ont des
compagnies professionnelles
il ya des professeurs comme anne marie
porras qui dirigent des centres de
formation mais c'est vrai aussi qu'on
peut venir que l'on peut venir tout
simplement pour le plaisir en famille
par exemple
donc ça peut être une vitrine pour les
danseurs mais une vitrine aussi
peut-être pour la ville de châteauroux
elle-même a je pense qu'il est
indéniable cette année que vu le
retentissement médiatique au niveau
national pour la ville de châteauroux
département de l'inde et la région
centre val de loire
il y à quelques pas à un retour sur
investissement est au niveau de
l'attractivité du territoire
le stage festival international de
châteauroux est vraiment plus
qu'intéressant et alors que commence à
se caractérise justement c'est à dire
que ça fait ça fait vivre un petit peu
la ville à travers ces commerces des
hôtels même qui a qu'eux qui accueille
les danseurs et chanteurs l'hôtellerie
bien sûr à travers les professeurs les
techniciens les stagiaires et puis les
festivaliers
et puis je dirais c'est surtout l'image
de là
il est positive cette intergénérationnel
de 12 ans à 70 ans
j'irai que c'est tout couleur aussi on
est gros on est petit on est rouge jaune
et vert on peut venir au stage
international et on sent bien que cette
fraternité qui règne durant la
manifestation
eh bien on va la voir ce soir lors de la
représentation